pas tous s'il est un mot un concept qui
a fait beaucoup rêver écrire les poètes
et les romanciers qui d'ailleurs ne
cessera de les faire rêver écrire fait
le mot temps à la recherche du temps
perdu le temps retrouvé le temps
immobile le temps est un songe au temps
suspends ton vol et cetera et cetera
et puis il ya aussi un beau poème une
admirable chansons de léo ferré avec le
temps qui exception exceptionnellement
valent à servir de musique pour le
générique d' apostrophes sens sera le
244e numéro voici un extrait du grand
échiquier jacques chancel léo ferré qui
chante avec le temps avec lui
avec le temps va tout s'en va
on oublie le visa plus
et l'homme oublie il avoir le coeur
quand ça bat lui c'est pas la peine
d'aller chercher plus loin
faut laisser faire c'est très bien
avec le temps
avec le temps va
tout s'emballe autres conad vais
chercher sous la pile hôtes ont deviné
au détour d'un regard entre les mots
entre les lignes sous le fard d'un
serment maquiller qui s'en va faire sa
nuit
avec le temps
tout s'évanouit
alors léo ferré il est l'âme à droite
pour deux ouvrages qui paraissent tous
les deux aux éditions plasma testament
phonographe et plus qui est un recueil
de vos deux chansons de vos poèmes nous
en parlerons de thaler et puis les
conversations vous avez eue avec
journaliste s'appelle françoise travaux
lady donc ferrer donc mais mission
placée à côté de vous cathy stéphan qui
est journaliste à quimper et qui publie
chez grasset son premier roman une
poignée d'eau dit il
la côtés de cathy stefan jean anglade
ancien professeur de lettres et
l'italien monf a surtout écrivain une
cinquantaine de livres des romans des
essais des des traductions aussi est
votre dernier roman paru chez julliard
sous le titre la bonne rosé est en phase
de boules célèbre auteur du cheval
d'orgueil pierre jakez hélias qui est
ici parce que non pas pour un nouveau
livre publié mais parce que vous avez
préfacé un admirable ouvrage d'antoine
silvert toinou le cri d'un enfant
auvergnats qui paraît dans l'excellente
collection terre humaine aux éditions
plon
et puis enfin karine berio qui est
critique littéraire qui est spécialiste
l'histoire de l'art traductrice et qui
publie son deuxième roman aux éditions
du seuil sous le titre par les noix de
louise léo ferré bas avec le temps dans
est-ce que vous vous rappelez dans je
sais pas dans quel était votre état
d'esprit dans quelles circonstances vous
avez écrit cette chanson projeté le
piémont italien faisant deux heures par
le music en désert ouais parce que je
sais pas et puis ça me scie séjour tout
pas en arrière mais là c'était quelqu'un
d'autre qui me qui me dicte et ça vous
savez on n'est pas de sommet
intermédiaire vous avez su pivot il ya
personne personne n'existe moi je suis
comme ça parce que allez savoir
je suis un chiffre et
je me suis loupé longe c'est ça les
paroles cette chanson qu'on retrouve
donc page 219 dans le testament
olographe et on lit ceci avec le temps
va tout s'en va on oublie les peuples et
passion qu'il en oublie les voix qui
vous disaient tout bas
les mots des pauvres gens ne rentrent
pas trop tard surtout ne prend pas froid
mais c'est pas vrai qu'on n'oublie pas
puisque au moment où vous dites ça moi
effectivement je revois des parents qui
ne disaient ne rendent pas trop tard ne
prend pas froid oui mon frère je mange
bio rente pape retard n'ont pas froid
tout le monde s'en fout roman laisse
rien dire et s'il met toujours
évidemment le prends pas froid mon petit
nom ne vous en parler elle n'oublie pas
il faut oublier le passé aussi cette
date
bon ya tout de même beaucoup de votre
passé dans ce livre oui parce que vous
savez ici testament olographe tam a
écrit mein voyage et d'amours fin à
peine
et puis si je dois laisser un jour
quelque chose on laissera rien
d'ailleurs je vous retrouve à sauter
bientôt je laisserais ma voix à quoi à
qui
cinq à six thèmes des droits d'auteur à
mes gosses qui essaieront de vivre sans
avoir de patron
moi j'ai jamais eu de patron 1 pourtant
ça alors je suis que les enfants n'est
pas de patron mais ça changera un jour
la sacem sera sauter tout va sauter on
picole po lyon avant que vous vouliez
gagner alors comme ça m'est donc ce
livre rassemble des poèmes vous a écrit
quelques textes en prose des pommes a
écrit certains sont devenus des chansons
très célèbre d'autres moins il ya des
photographies il ya aussi des lettres et
cetera testament phonogrammes mais pour
moi testament
ça évoque le cimetière ans je trouve
qu'il n'ya rien de plus vivant que les
mots qui sont rassemblés dans ce livre
et oui mais le testament ça se fait
avant de mourir moi je peux mourir tout
de suite là j'aurais sûrement oui oui
comprise oui le testament
je fait pas trop vous êtes mort vous
êtes au courant oui vous faites avant ok
c'est un joli titre oui oui mais enfin
c'est pas que c'est plutôt un livre qui
je sais pas quel est votre âge votre
avis vous pouvez pas c'est un livre de
vie plutôt très très beau et il est au
delà des chansons de léo ferré encore
parce qu'on connaît tous des folios fait
raymond connais certaines chansons et là
il ya les extraits de ferrer il y à ces
manques et ce qu'il veut cacher le fait
un petit peu du façon tellement non
alors qu'il veut pas caché c'est vrai il
a des manques et c'est émouvant c'est un
homme fort quand même
c'est un livre c'est le livre d'un homme
fort était un très beau livre vous parle
évidemment des mots alors c'est dans
l'autre livre vous confier beaucoup dans
cet autre livre dit donc ferrer s'état
nice bien fait on apprend beaucoup de
choses effectivement c'est à dire que je
connais françoise depuis longtemps a
beaucoup de talent et je les ai vus
pendant trois ans venait de temps en
temps quand je chantais elle avait son
petit magnétophone et puis un jour là
fait ce livre et je trouve que il est
remarquable pas par moi mais par elle
s'était fait remarquer bon allez vous
parler des mots parler un peu des mots
de testament un peu des mots aussi dans
l'est donc ferrer et à certains moments
vous dites je malienne dans les mots et
puis après il ya cette phrase du trou
superbe on ne fait pas la poésie avec
des tracts on l'a fait avec sa gueule
bien ouverte sur les verbe habituel et
de préférence actifs
oui et comment il ya le mot c'est c'est
peu la révolution c'est les mots 1 c'est
pas facile moi je viens ici avec une
avec une petit machin d'une enclume un
mitraillette jour descend et après on
mets en taule et puis après qu'on l'ait
marine a pris à personne sa maman si je
mets le le ver dans le fruit et le fruit
se trouve que c'est le la tête de
quelqu'un mais le bon verts et spa alors
là c'était important est une arme
redoutable les mots seulement il faut
savoir s'en servir
il faut recommencer à la ré apprendre
bien réinventer le c'est trop tard
maintenant je vous dis bientôt fera
sauter pessimistes des milieux tout va
sauter non je suis pas pessimiste vous
avez des gens ici c'est marrant ils font
des projets c'est extraordinaire on a
des projets oui la prochaine apostrophe
salines je sais qu'il va venir
oui alors les mots comment est ce que
vous vous battez avec eux ou bien est-ce
que j'ai l'impression qu'il ya leur
faire l'amour quand vous écrivez
bon si je fais pas l'amour c'est l'amour
et les femmes oui ma femme je suis avec
une femme je parle jamais oh purée mais
alors je dois dire une chose que je
répète souvent parce que quand on me
demande est les gens n'avaient pas
demandé et vous parlez des mots et je
dois dire que je repense vous êtes à
l'heure que je suis l'intermédiaire
c'est à dire que j'ai l'habitude de
travailler à la machine à écrire
parsys trail avec la plume avec le stylo
machin jeunes et qui fait tout à fait
autre chose
1 et la machine j'ai l'habitude et alors
dès que sa part ça y est ça s'arrête pas
alors c'est pas moi comprenez c'est pour
ça que j'essaie d'expliquer en disant
que le mot vient mettons centièmes un
millième de seconde avant à penser voilà
et c'est pour ça que c'est pas moi qui
fais observer de folie là dedans une
façon d'expliquer le le miracle de 2
d'un mec comme ça qui écrit et pif qui
s'est passé des tas de gens parce que
vous ils ont une époque fantastique
vous savez e baudelaire verlaine rimbaud
sont les trois grands poètes du dix
neuvième siècle
s'il avait été chanteur si un jour il ya
eu des disques et bien on les
appellerait pas des boîtes
vous savez comment les appellera
ateliers d'eas et les auteurs
compositeurs interprètes à bon port vous
les avez mis en musique
ah oui mais parce que je joue mon devoir
d'amour comprenez que si me rencontrent
quelque part nous entends je les vois un
peu mais je ne distingue pas bien mais
s'il me rends compte quelque part il me
millions il m'embrasse je vous ai fait
connaître
pas parce que c'est moi passer la
musique c'est tout et c'est tout ça
c'est une époque monstrueuse est
extraordinaire vous avez dit battre pour
deux pianos
j'ai mis ma droit ivan musique
alors j'ai créé après un puits
apollinaire zone connaissez assez
difficile je suis là comme ça pis je
pleurais en chantant et vous avez une
machine à imprimer chez vous quand on
imagine imprimé chez soi c'est peut-être
qu'on aime un peu le papier longuement
fait c'est surtout parce qu'on aime les
mots oui c'est sûr j'ai trouvé le jour
les livres eux les beaux livres
on fait moins beau livre veut dire du
techniquement matériellement face en
même temps l'importance tout va sauter
oui mais tu as après trente ans on lit
aussi et dans le charbon point sa
vieille machine je peux j'aurais pu
imprimer ces lieux c'est ça moi je
n'aurais imprimés mille comprend un
espace pour faire un travail j'ai eu un
compte aujourd'hui j'ai honte quand je
vois je le dis pas mais quand je vois
quelqu'un qui travaille avec ses mains
sont toujours très ému et alors
un jour j'ai acheté une machine peut
être de la révolte
c'est ce que l'on dit souvent debout et
d'ailleurs vous avez mis en musique des
poèmes de rimbaud verlaine baudelaire
quitter ou qui sont des poètes le site
la révolte est ce que vous pensez qu'on
ne peut pas écrire de poèmes de chansons
quand on n ont pas conformiste mais
quand on n'est pas contre ils font que
ça à tous vous écouter les chansons sont
tous contents non ah bon j'ai été un peu
étonné ah oui sont tous pour bon c'est
le dentifrice je sois gip sous ma chère
juste par la guerre je vous raconte ça
vous ferrez je m'en tiens le pharmacien
que d'un copain non la peau et je vais
aller acheter du dentifrice et alors je
dirais pourquoi prendre et je lui dis de
textes et vidéos
jeudi des lois du même type de pas des
méthodes il s'est tourné maintenant ça
existe et vous plaît oui je veux bien le
meilleur dans votre livre
oui c'est pas mal mais c'est pas mal ce
qui est important c'est que moi je ne
savais pas que ça existait c'est à dire
que là aussi les nouveaux acquis à
parler ou pourquoi des vous enlevez
retirer de votre répertoire
la chanson les anarchistes non je vais
remise n'est pas bon alors pourquoi la
fourmi pour pour envoyer la couleur
nouveau après tout ce qui passe puis six
mois et puis moi je me suis dit j'arrive
je vais pas chanter truc comme ça je
vais arriver en disant voilà c'est comme
ça
le drapeau noir c'est encore un drapeau
mais c'est quand même un grand point
noir c'est pas grave bon et alors je lui
ai remise je l'avais quittée parce que
on me prenait pour céder venu j'ai vu
l'anarchiste enfin c'était devenu un
drapeau ça m'embête
vous avez au fond contre tous les
drapeaux y compris drapeau noir je
préfère drapeau noir
mais si elle n'avait pas ça serait mieux
ce serait mieux oui et au fond votre
chanson est devenue à ninh et vous êtes
contre tous les hymnes et oui est ce que
vous dites contre ça ah bon je dis rien
mais vous citez souvent le sait vers
d'apollinaire mon beau navire où ma
mémoire
avons nous avons nous assez navigué
alors est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous avez
vous parlé apollinaire qui elle veut le
grand pote j'ai dit qu'il y avait trois
tempêtes aux chances 19e la vingtième
heure
il est mort en 1918 et il a il va avoir
il aurait eu 100 ans le 26 août prochain
c'est le grand poète apollinaire et ces
deux pays m'a beaucoup aidé en lisant je
pense que j'ai trouvé mon chemin et les
ans il a été dit l'était polonais il a
été volé chez les frères hamelin peau et
vous êtes même d'un coup et j'ai des
brèches des frères à monaco non cotées a
lors des guerres d'italie
déjà vous navire ma mémoire avant de
verser dans cette ode de dôme jean par
ses chambres à la semag et de la belle
au bois
c'est fantastique
mais qu'est ce que répondait à la
question d'un polymère quelle question
avons nous assez navigué
oui peut-être
il ya un point d'interrogation oui des
fois un an où on aurait envie de [ __ ]
en l'air mais je crois que c'est la
seule chose qu'il ne faut pas faire bon
c'est si je vois je vous demande une
maison je vais jouer une araignée par
terre ce qui déjà restitué du mollet
droit
un jour j'ai mis du couple de les voir
c'est une poêle rival jugé vassili larié
web le les familles une soupe de lait et
j'étais très content et savent pas ce
type à la lumière le chevalet c'est pas
qu'il va mourir
le chien non plus nous savons bien il
faut faire semblant de ne pas savoir
qu'on va mourir parce que la mort c'est
envisageable en java très belle femme
effrité mais vous dites un moment vous
pouvez pas séparer la notion du temps et
la notion de la mort je sais pas ça par
vous avez d'accord sur les talons des
avoirs vous savez cet inquiétant parce
que la mort dies
le néant c'est le lait ordinaire l'album
posée d'ici vous l'expliqué le mort hier
je disais l'autre jour à la maison tu te
dire y'a rien ça au niger a vendu vendu
10 à rien c'est bien au moins trois
délits qui a rien avec l'humour avec le
l'esprit avec le ce qu'on t'a appris
rien ne se passait rien dans un monde
j'ai dit à mon fils il ya dix ans alors
ils me regardent et m'écoutent et comme
ça il dit j'ai dit c'est que rien on
peut même pas en parler
il n'y voit pas pas parce que si tu dis
rien j'ai dix ans tu as la notion du
rien c'est l'histoire de deux du néant
oui ça n'est pas sorti sa retraite tout
son génie être le néant c'est vrai donc
il faut être raisonnable et ça veut dire
ces choses qui m'inquiètent ça je suis
peut-être un peu trop long voyage
acquise il ya ce n'est pas rien alors on
va annoncer foisonnant c'est frv sens ça
fuse dans toutes les directions
il faut s'accrocher à ces cantons et
envers l'irlande avion qu'il y a de
drôles de vent comme vous lise et léo
ferré vous il accroché au bastingage
ouais je trouve vous régaler les mots
quand vous avez une espèce de sensualité
lieu d'y veiller cathy stefan veut le
montrer un trait des lettres dans le
livre de léo ferré et j'aimerais lire ce
poème c'est le permet
bon nombre hélas ma table et je ne
saurais te dire comment le soleil
factice des langues s'en arrange
je sais que tu es là et que tu ne m'a
jamais quitté j'étais dans mois au
profond dans le sang et du cours dans
mes veines tu parle dans mon coeur et tu
te purifie dans mes poumons je t'aime je
te bois je vis je t'en veux laisser bien
je t'apporte ce soir mon enfant de
longtemps celui que je me suis fait tout
seul qui me ressemble qui te ressemble
qui sort de ton ventre de ton ventre qui
est dans ma tête
tu es là
la fille la compagne et la pole de ce
dieu tout brûlant qui éclaire nos nuits
depuis que nous faisons nos nuits je
t'aime il me semble qu'on m'a tirée de
toi est content a sorti deux mois quand
tu pars je m'en chante quand je chante
je te parle
nous venons d'ailleurs tous les deux
personne ne le sait quand je mourrai
tout pourra plus vivre que dans la larme
qui n'aura plus un moment à toi tu seras
mienne par delà ce chemin qui nous
séparera si je t'appellerai et tu
deviendras si tu mourrais tu
m'appellerait je suis la vie pour toi et
la peine et la joie et la mort je meurs
dans toi et nos moeurs assemblée seront
une nouvelle vie unique comme si deux
étoiles se rencontrait comme si elle
devait le faire de toute éternité
comme si elle se coller pour jouir à
jamais ce que tu fais c'est bien puisque
tu m'aimes ce que je fais c'est bien
puisque je t'aime à ce jour à cette
heure pas toujours mon amour ou bien
merci qu'à 19 ans et c'était pas du tout
prévu et bien c'est spontané le